I've got some very important breaking
news to bring you this literally just in
from Lancashire police who have told us
that a body has been found in the river
why let me read you the statement in its
entirety this morning Sunday the 19th of
February you may be aware of police
activity around the river near to Saint
Michael's on wire we want to provide you
with an update on that activity into mum
Rashid was telling us obviously about
that search a short time ago police say
we were called at 11 36 this morning to
reports of a body in the river wire
close to rawcliff Road an underwater
search team and specialist officers have
subsequently attended the scene entered
the water and have sadly recovered a
body now please go on to say that no
formal identify identification has been
carried out yet so they are unable to
say whether this is Nicola bully at this
time procedures to identify the body are
ongoing we are currently treating the
death as unexplained Nicholas family
have been informative developments our
thoughts are with them at this most
difficult of times we ask that their
privacy is respected let us bring in
straight away our correspondent intimate
Rasheed who is in St Michael's on wire
where of course that police activity has
been focused for the past two and a half
hours and you broke the news that a
search was underway so what appears to
be an extremely sad development now
isn't he
and a very significant development let's
just reiterate what Lancashire police
have released to us in the last few
moments this morning Sunday 19th
February you may be aware of police
activity what we've been reporting on
over the last hour or so around the
river near to St Michael's we want to
provide you with an update on that
activity they were called police say at
11 36 to reports of a body in the river
wire close to rawcliff Road an
underwater search team and specialist
officers have subsequently attended the
scene entered the water and have sadly
recovered a body no formal
identification has yet been carried out
so we are unable to say whether this is
Nicola bully at this time procedures to
identify the body are ongoing we are
currently treating the death as
unexplained Nicholas family have been
informed of developments and our
thoughts are with them at this most
difficult of times we ask that their
privacy is respected what do we know so
far well since around 10 past one a
police helicopter was circling the sky
flying quite low to the river wire about
a mile down from where Nicola bully was
last seen around over three weeks ago at
a bench in the village of Saint
Michael's on wire where her phone still
unlocked was found her dog Willow and
the dog's harness as well so ten past
one the helicopter flying for around 20
to 25 minutes quite low towards the
river wire That Was Then replaced by a
police drone and there was subsequently
a number of police officers that arrived
at the scene divers into the water a
police had cordoned off roads stopping
any members of the public ourselves as
well getting close to what was happening
there and then more police officers
arrived later on in including a
detective superintendent and the senior
investigating officer on the search for
Nicola bully Rebecca Smith then in the
last 20 minutes or so we've seen a
forensic tent has been erected by police
officers along with uh crime scene
investigating officers as well and the
information that's been released from
Lancashire police in the last few
minutes is that they were called at 11
36 to reports of a body in the river
wire the underwater search team and
specialist officers attended the scene
they entered the water and sadly they
have now recovered a body they say that
there is no formal identification as of
yet and they are unable to say whether
that body
is that of the missing mum of two 45
year old Nicola bully but they are
carrying out procedures to identify that
body they say that they are currently
treating the death as unexplained and
Nicholas family have been informed